brian is with us in San Antonio Texas
hey Brian how are you Dave I'm better
than I deserve
oh how can I help hey listen I am super
pumped because I just got a huge
promotion a new job and everything and
so I want to take all this extra money
my wife and I we've been a Deford since
we've been married basically with
student loans and the whole nine yards
now with a couple of kids my question is
we've been living you know every you'll
be more like every other people will be
here a paycheck every two weeks so we
get the Terry paycheck we pay off debt
or pay up bills and you're I think your
plan is by the month you do at the end
of month you get a budget and you set it
up for the entire month question is how
do i how do we adjust ourselves to you
know to the end of the month basically
well you you can look at the calendar
and you do a unique budget for each
month and when you look at the calendar
you can tell how many paychecks you're
gonna get right yeah yeah you're either
gonna get to where you're gonna get
three twice a year you get three if
you're on two weeks yeah that's how the
way my wife is I'm just saying you know
I could say the 15th we get paid you
know we've got things we have to take
care of with first readers or diapers or
whatever we hold that money so we just
start the budget at the end of the month
you don't have to hold money start
somebody you have money coming in and
money going out now all I want you to
have money coming in and has the money
before the money goes out I want you to
tell it where to go you don't have to
have a whole month saved up to start a
budget okay you're not getting it let me
try again
no okay you you have what's your take
home pay a month around there between
the both of us yes it's going to be
about 6,000 okay so six thousand dollars
comes in six thousand dollars goes out
and you don't know what happened right
now exactly barely made it okay all I
want you to do is before it happens I
want you to write six thousand dollars
at the top of the page and you can write
it up two columns if you want for the
two paychecks okay for the dates that
they come in right and then I want you
to tell that six thousand dollars where
it's going to go before it leaves
it's gonna leave just like it left
before it's just gonna leave now
intentionally you're giving it a mission
you're giving it a job to do and you're
not really going to change a ton of what
you're doing because you still got to
pay the house payments you still got to
pay the lights and water you still got
to buy food right correct and that
doesn't change the only difference is
you're gonna do this on purpose on paper
before the month begins so before this
next month gets here I want you to write
down what you're gonna do with next
month's money when it comes in rather
than it just coming in and going back
out with no plan okay I got you know you
don't have to be ahead of it a month you
know I have to have six thousand dollars
saved up to start because you're not
riding a six thousand dollar check its
first of the month you're gonna write it
out of each cheque as the out of each
paycheck as the paychecks come in I got
you okay I got you it's treating it like
a business that's it money comes in
income comes in you're just finding it
out is okay I got ya it's already it's
already spent on paper it's already
allocated and given a mission on paper
before it comes in yeah instead of it
just coming in and going back out and we
go crap we're broke again okay yeah that
makes sense
okay then that's what wool that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna sit down and
get that budget right now and get this
going so cool now do you have a copy of
the book do you have a copy the book the
Total Money Makeover no I don't I was
gonna go grab one but you're gonna get
one now it's my get my gift to you you
hold on Kelly he'll pick up and we'll
have that for you thanks for the call
you